Do you know what my cat wants to promote now?
A series of youth and consequences, which is now on YouTube red
You can register for a 30 day free trial.
I was thinking about recently
How my friends are inspiring
I want to be you when bigger. one day
My friendships have become a source of inspiration and support in my life for me. Especially my friends
I am surrounded by women who have motivation
Compassion and intelligence
I am very grateful for their knowledge. All I have the opportunity to see them feel reassured and calm
I'm always
I was surprised when they broke up and for a while I was addressing them about the subject so "Oh girl stop talking this way.
You are an amazing artist
It is difficult for people to resist and you are funny and beautiful
Haha thanks
Hmmm "
This did not meet the point
I mean this is normal. I would find it a mockery too. Because your friends will definitely support you
Because they are your friends, they will laugh at you and tell you how amazing you are
That is why a new approach has been taken ... "It also seems that the spiritual twin will either be his balance
Or Pisces or Cancer Choose a Libra You do not want another water tower.
Cancer and Pisces are water towers? I did not know this
I am a failure because I know this thing
Do not say this way with my girlfriend stop this. This is very aggressive
After the experiment I found that this approach works because something is about this approach
Re-frame the way you talk to yourself and remind you that you will not accept that a friend talks to you this way
Why do you accept this talk from yourself?
And it's also very enjoyable. Especially when your friend is on the other side of the room
"Ah, I do not know why I became a writer everything I write is very bad stop telling this about my girlfriend"
Or when they do not know that you have heard what they are saying
"I'm so ugly that you stop saying this about my girlfriend"
Or even if they think about it, "Why do I bother from the beginning, all my views are stupid
Stop saying this about my girlfriend "
So, if your amazing talented friend breaks himself, be a good friend and defend them
Against themselves
Especially against themselves. As we're talking about it, thanks to my friend Ana for being in the video today
She is not only an excellent dancer, she is also a comedian and water colors artist
The audio is painted in the background. I am an acana